pour son premier déplacement dans les
yvelines en tant que candidate aux
élections régionales
audrey pulvar a échangé avec des
syndicalistes cfdt de l'usiné renault de
flins à l'horizon 2024 plus aucun
véhicule ne devrait y être construit une
décision difficile à comprendre pour la
candidate
renault est un groupe qui a reçu des
aides de l'état y compris dans cette
région y compris pour le pour le site de
flins est que cette aide n'est jamais
été conditionné que les aides de la
région n'ait jamais été conditionné non
seulement à des principes des
obligations environnementales mais aussi
sociale ça semble inimaginable
aujourd'hui les salariés de renault
flins produisent la zoé et la micra de
nissan avec l'arrêt de ses productions
il ne resterait sur l' usine que des
activités annexes
il y a un savoir-faire à flins depuis
des années c'est fabriquer des véhicules
on a su faire même trois véhicules
différents des électriques déterminent
eux-mêmes des véhicules de partenaires
on était la première usine à fabriquer
avec électrique pour le groupe
et toute cette expérience cette
expertise on peut pas accepter qu'à
disparaissent demain c'est qu'ils
craignent c'est l'impact sur l'emploi et
sur le tissu économique local
on sait qu'il ya un emploi direct dans
l'usiné de flins génère 10 emplois
indirects dans la région
donc on pense que il y aurait 40 mille
familles à plate et directement par
l'arrêt de la fabrication
et ça aussi c'est pas tolérable pour nos
enfants pour l'avenir et pour les
commerçants
et voilà et pour tous les jeunes aussi
de la région voilà voilà notre combat va
dans ce sens là audrey pulvar soutient
donc les salariés de l'usiné dans leur
combat de son côté la direction avait
présenté fin 2020 aux représentants
syndicaux son projet de reconversion
dans le reconditionnement automobile